hello my name is sari and on behalf of
simple n I like to welcome you to this
tutorial on cyber security training
let's first understand what is cyber
security cyber security is the process
of using best practices to protect
systems network and programs from
cyberattacks a good place to start the
discussion is by understanding the
motives of the cyber criminals
why do cyber criminals attack in this
example this vault contains some
valuable money and the second vault also
contains some money now let us secure
the vault B with a lock now between
these two vaults which one do you think
is the cyber criminal likely to attack
well most definitely vault a which is
unlocked the cyber criminal would need
to put in lesser effort to attack this
unlocked vault let's look at another
example now this time involved a secured
with a lock which will now take five
minutes to unlock and similarly vault
bees also secured with a lock and this
will take 15 minutes to unlock now again
between these two vaults which one is
the cyber criminal likely to attack well
most definitely vault a again as it will
take less time to unlock this vault in
this third scenario vault a has
$1,000,000 and vault B has 10 million
dollars now between these two vaults
which one is the cyber criminal most
likely to attack well this time the
cyber criminal will definitely attack
vault B which contains more money now
that we've looked at some examples let's
take a look at what's in it for you in
this tutorial first we'll understand the
concept of cyber security next we'll
discuss the basic terminologies used in
cyber security we will discuss how the
internet works and the basic protocols
used on the internet understanding
common types of attacks is very
important for you to be able to protect
against them and lastly we'll discuss
about malware's its functions and its
sources well I'm sure you're aware of
the buzzword cyber security but let's
understand and what cyber security means
cybersecurity is the technology and
process of using industry best practices
to protect systems network and programs
from cyberattacks cybersecurity attacks
are usually aimed at accessing changing
or destroying sensitive data extorting
money from users or interrupting normal
business processes everyone relies on
critical infrastructure like power
plants hospitals public transport system
and financial service companies securing
these and other organizations is
essential to keeping our society
functioning some people tend to confuse
cybersecurity with information security
are actually different their
capabilities are different information
security is another way of saying there
are security in other words protecting
the confidentiality integrity and
availability of data and this involves
the protection of information and
information systems from unauthorized
access use disclosure disruption
modification our destruction Information
Security deals with the protection of
information even if it's stored in a
file cabinet while on the other hand
cyber security deals with protecting
data and information from outside
sources in cyberspace or the internet so
someone could likely be a cyber security
expert without being an information
security expert or vice versa here are
some of the basic terminologies that you
need to be aware of in the world of
cyber security
they are networked internet internet
protocols IP address MAC address DNS
DHCP router malware virus warms BOTS and
finally hash function and values we will
be discussing these points in detail in
the upcoming topics let's start a
discussion with understanding what the
network is a computer network is a group
of two or more computers connected
together so that they can communicate
and share data with each other for
example there are two computers
exchanging data between them and in this
example there are four computers
connected to each other these computers
in the network could be sharing
resources like a printer
or a file server a cybersecurity attack
would most likely involve the use of
this computer network
the most common resource shared today is
connection to the Internet
now the Internet is a global system of
interconnected computer networks that
use the Internet Protocol suite which is
the tcp/ip to link devices worldwide via
dedicated routers and servers when two
computers are connected over the
internet they can send and receive all
kinds of fast range of information
resources and services such as the world
wide web email telephony video and
file-sharing several security primarily
deals with attacks originating from the
Internet when two computers are
communicating with each other over the
internet they need to be able to
understand each other and speak the same
language the data that is being
transferred or received cannot just
follow any path to control the flow of
data and connectivity there are a set of
rules which are used which unknown as
internet protocols the protocol used on
the Internet is commonly known as tcp/ip
because the foundational protocols in
the suite are the transmission control
protocol which is the TCP and the
internet protocol which is the IP
another important concept to understand
is the IP address an Internet Protocol
address or the IP address is a unique
logical address assigned to each device
connected to a computer network that
uses the Internet Protocol for
communication
this unique address is designed to allow
one connected computer to communicate
with another device over the IP based
network like the internet most IP
address looks like this one six eight
dot 194 dot sixty 4.10 an IP address
provides an identity to a network device
on the Internet similar to a home or
business address that supplies a
specific physical location with an
identifiable address devices in the
network are differentiated from each
other through this IP addresses similar
to an IP address is the MAC address
which is a unique Hardware
identification number that is given to
every device that connects on the
network the media access control or the
MAC addresses are generally assigned by
the vendor or the manufacturer of every
network card such as the Ethernet card
or the Wi-Fi card
unlike IP addresses MAC address is
permanent and therefore cannot be
changed MAC address is generally 48 bits
and written as 12 digit hexadecimal
notation most MAC addresses look like
this t 8f c 9 3 c 5 a 5 e 0 this unique
MAC address is used to identify the
unique device so that data can be
delivered to this particular device the
domain name system of the DNS can be
considered as the phonebook of the
internet we humans use domain names like
google.com which is easy to remember
however the computers only understand an
IP address and does not understand a
domain name this is where a DNS server
is used to translate a domain name to
its corresponding IP address for example
if you want to browse google.com type
google.com in the browser URL this
request goes to a DNS server the DNS
server finds the IP address of
google.com the DNS server sends the IP
address back to the computer and the
computer connects to google.com using
the IP address
there are several attacks on a DNS
system a DNS poisoning attack is a type
of cyberattack which involves poofing
DNS entries which can result in a user
being diverted from a legitimate server
to a fraudulent one not many are aware
of the DHCP protocol the dynamic host
configuration protocol in short known as
DHCP it is a management protocol that is
used to automatically assign an IP
address to any device so that they can
communicate using the internet protocol
DHCP automates and centrally manages
these configurations rather than
requiring network administrators to
manually assign IP addresses to all
network devices
suppose there are these three computers
that need IP addresses to communicate on
the network
the DHCP communicates with these
computers and automatically assigns them
with an IP address along with other
network details such as a subnet
information default gateway and DNS
address the first system is assigned the
IP address of 1000 that is assigned
10.0.0.0 system is assign 10.0.0.0 where
that there are several DHCP related
attacks which include DHCP spoofing and
DHCP starvation which can lead to
availability issues what are the most
important device that is used and the
Internet is the router well as router is
a networking device that transmits data
packets between different networks using
a routing protocol a simple example of a
router is the Wi-Fi router device that
you probably use at home to connect to
the internet your local devices can
connect to the router and the router can
route the traffic onto the internet
making it possible for you to connect to
the internet using your local systems
router security is a top priority a
security hole in the network can expose
you to attackers and your organization
at risk most routers provides enough
security tools to harden your network
against possible cyberattacks provided
that you take the time to configure them
to your advantage
malware or malicious software is any
program or file that is intentionally
designed to disrupt or damage a computer
system types of malware can include a
wide range of concepts including virus
ransomware warms Trojans rootkits
key loggers adware spyware BOTS remote
access trojan logic bombs and backdoors
we will discuss some of these Malory's
in the upcoming topics a computer virus
is a malware or a malicious program
which is designed to spread from one
system to another through
self-replication and to perform any of
the wide range of malicious activities
the malicious activities performed via
virus include data deletion corruption
alteration and exfiltration an example
of a virus is the Melissa virus which is
first detected in 1999 it is a macro
virus that was spread through email
attachments the best countermeasure
against viruses is an anti-virus or
anti-malware scanner that is updated
regularly another form of malware that
is closely related to a virus is a warm
warms are self-contained applications
that don't require a host file or hard
drive in fact warmth typically I focused
on replication and distribution rather
than on direct damage and destruction an
example is a WTAE to dot al-qura dot F
which is a warm that attempts to
propagate through various p2p
file-sharing networks such as LAN wire
warms are designed to exploit a specific
vulnerability in a system such as
operating system protocol service or
application and then use that flaw to
spread themselves to other systems with
the same flaw they may be used to
deposit viruses logic bombs ransomware
backdoors are BOTS for botnets or they
may perform direct virus like activities
on their own count images for worms are
the same as for viruses with the
addition of keeping systems patched the
term BOTS or botnet is a shortened form
of the phrase robot Network it is used
to describe a malicious computer program
that is used by a hacker to control your
system remotely a botnet is a
combination of traditional dos attacks
into a concept known as a distributed
denial of service attack a botnet can be
used to perform any type of malicious
activity although they're most often
used to perform distributed of denial
flooding attacks botnets can be used to
automatically send spam emails or to
retrieve webpages or to change computer
settings or perform any other malicious
activity botnets are possible because
most computers around the world are
accessible over the Internet and many of
those computers have weak security the
best defense against the botnet is to
keep your systems patched and hardened
hashing is a one-way cryptographic
function that takes in an input of any
length and produces a fixed size unique
output known as a hash value a hash
value serves as a unique code to detect
when the original data source has been
altered since the altered file will
produce a different hash value passwords
should never be stored in plain text
we should use a hashing function to
store passwords let's take an example to
understand this instead of storing the
password ABC at 1 2 3 as plain text a
salt value is appended to the plaintext
password and then the result is hashed
this is referred to as the hashed value
a salt is randomly generated which is
unique for each password
both the salt value and the hashed value
are stowed together in this section we
will discuss the common types of attacks
which consists of distributed
denial-of-service man-in-the-middle
attack email attacks and password
attacks distributed denial-of-service is
a type of attack where multiple
compromised systems which are often
infected with bots are used to target a
single system causing a denial of
service attack in this example the
attacker prepares a botnet controller
for the DDoS attack the attacker uses
this botnet controller to compromise the
server's the botnet controller installs
a malicious piece of software called
bots in the compromised server these
compromised servers can be referred to
as zombie systems the attacker then
remote controls these servers to attack
a victim's server in this example
facebook.com this DDoS attack is
intended to temporarily or indefinitely
disrupt the services of facebook.com now
a legitimate user trying to access
facebook.com is unable to do so since
all of Facebook's resources are used up
in the DDoS attack a man-in-the-middle
attack is a communications eavesdropping
attack attackers position themselves in
the communication stream between a
client and server are any two
communicating entities the client and
server believed that they are
communicating directly with each other
they may even have secured on encrypted
communication links however the attacker
can access and potentially modifying the
communications one of the most common
targets of man-in-the-middle attack is
an online banking site in this example a
bank customer is communicating with the
bank an attacker sits between the
connection of two parties and observes
the traffic the hacker
creates a connection with the customer
and then creates a connection with the
bank notice how both the bank and
customer assumed that the system they
are talking to is the legitimate system
the man in the middle appears to be the
bank to the customer and it appears to
be the customer to the bank in this
banking scenario the hacker could steal
the card information or see that a user
is making a transfer and change the
destination account number or amount
being sent countermeasures to
man-in-the-middle attacks include strong
encryption protocols and the use of
strong authentication the combination of
username and password is the most common
identification and authentication system
at the same time they're the weakest
form relying solely on password is in
true security the strength of a password
is generally measured in the amount of
time and effort involved in breaking the
password through various forms of
attacks password guessing attacks
because of an easy to guess password is
very common against websites and web
servers some of the common types of
password attacks are a dictionary attack
brute-force attack key logger shoulder
surfing and a rainbow table attack let's
understand these attacks in the upcoming
topics a dictionary attack performs
password guessing by using a
pre-existing list of possible passwords
password lates can include millions of
possible passwords often two password
lists or dictionaries are constructed
around topics thus if an attacker knows
basic information about you as a person
they can attempt exploit human nature's
tendency to select passwords using words
common or familiar to you for example if
an attacker knows that you work in the
automobile industry you have dogs and
you enjoyed traveling they can select
password dictionaries that include words
acronyms and phases common to those
subjects dictionary attacks are
relatively fast operations but they have
a low rate of success against targets
with the knowledge of password security
or whose systems and Falls reasonable
levels of password length and complexity
a brute-force attack is designed to try
every possible valid combinations of
Kerik
to construct possible passwords starting
with single characters and adding
characters as it churns through the
process in an attempt to discover a
specific password used by the user
account such attacks are always
successful given enough time whereas
simple and short passwords can be
discovered amazingly quickly with a
brute-force approach longer and complex
passwords can take a long period of time
possibly into millions of years of
computational time for complex passwords
containing 16 or more characters a
keylogger is a form of malware that
recalls the keystrokes typed into the
system's keyboard this is typically done
covertly so that the person using the
keyboard is unaware that their actions
are being monitored the captured
keystrokes are then uploaded to the
attacker for analysis and exploitation
key loggers are most often used for
stealing passwords and other
confidential information
many anti-malware scanners include
signatures for key loggers to detect
these type of abusive software a key
logger infection might exhibit sluggish
keyboard response required typing keys
twice to get them to be recognized by
the system and cause overall system
performance degradation shoulder surfing
occurs when someone is able to literally
watch over a users shoulder to view the
keyboard or view their display this
could allow them to learn a password or
see information that is confidential
private are simply not for their eyes
this is specially effective in crowded
places where a person uses a computer
smartphone or ATM often shoulder surfing
is stopped by dividing worker groups by
sensitivity levels using lock doors and
they should not work on sensitive data
wine in public space such as coffee shop
or on a plane
privacy filter screen is also an
effective solution to prevent shoulder
surfing attack since the hashing
algorithm is not reversible
you might think it is impossible to
break a hash however there are methods
to do so rainbow table attacks are a
type of attack that attempts to discover
the password from the hash with a
rainbow table all of the following
hashes are computed in advance
in other words it create a series of
tables each has all the possible to
letter three letter for letter and so
forth combinations and the hash of the
combination using a known hashing
algorithm like md5 sha-1 etc now if you
saw the table for a given hash the
letter combination in the table that
produced the hash must be the password
that you are seeking social engineering
is a form of attack that exploits human
nature and human behavior social
engineering attacks take two primary
forms convincing someone to perform an
unauthorized operation are convincing
someone to reveal confidential
information for example the victim may
be fooled into believing that a person
on the phone is someone to be respected
and trusted such as a trusted IT
professional in just about every case in
social engineering the attacker tries to
convince the victim to perform some
activity or reveal a piece of
information that they shouldn't such as
their password the result of a
successful attack is information leakage
or the attacker being granted logical or
physical access to a secure environment
email or electronic mail is the most
common method of exchanging digital
messages on the Internet the first email
was sent in 1971 when a computer
engineer used the @ symbol to designate
the recipient of the email at its core
an email is simply a text message from
one user to another advancing technology
has added extra features along the way
of course like image and file
attachments links and embedded maps when
you send and receive email you use an
email client which allows you to compose
and read emails from other computer
users your email client can be web-based
meaning you check it through a web
browser example include Gmail office 365
Zoho or it can be an application on your
computer like Outlook and Thunderbird
when John sends an email to Jack it
appears that the email is sent directly
from John's system to Jack's system
however that is not how email really
works it is much more complex than that
this is how an email really works it
involves several
mail servers along with DNS servers
after John's SMTP client establishes a
reliable communication channels to the
SMTP server the session is opened with a
greeting by the server usually
containing its fully qualified domain
name in this case SMTP sauce comm the
mail server approaches the DNS server to
resolve the MX record the DNS server
replies with a resolved IP address of
the destination server the source mail
server is now able to establish a
reliable communication with the
destination SMTP mail server and now
Jack is able to receive the email in his
email client using the pop3 or IMAP
protocols let's understand the type of
email attacks phishing is one of the
most common attacks and spoofing and
email attachments let's understand these
attacks in a little more detail phishing
is a form of social engineering attack
focused on stealing credentials or
identity information from any potential
target it is based on the concept of
fishing for information phishing attack
is used to obtain sensitive information
such as usernames passwords credit card
details or other personally identifiable
information by masquerading as a
trustworthy entity for example a bank a
service provider or a merchant phishing
attack generally involves an email to
encourage people to share their details
in this example Brian receives a fake
email which mentions that his ABC bank
account was going to expire today
creating a sense of urgency
how does brine find out that it was a
spam well Brian does not have a ABC bank
account but what if someone actually had
an account with ABC Bank it is quite
likely that the person would click on
the given link and become victim to the
phishing attack well it is important to
note that the banks do not send emails
like this you should choose to ignore
this email or report the matter to your
bank immediately email spoofing refers
to an email with a forged sender address
to make it look as if it came from some
legitimate user this is a common
technique used by phishing attacks spam
and malware to make the
emails appear to be coming from
legitimate sources such as governmental
authorities insurance companies and
banks in this example bill receives a
spoofed email from his manager asking
him to share his password well it is
quite likely that bill may share his
password if his unaware of the email
being spoofed as a good security
practice never share your password on
email or for that matter never ever
share your password with anyone while
email attachments are a convenient way
to send files like images documents
audios or videos it could be misused to
share something which is malicious
attackers might send you spoofed emails
such as invoices encouraging you to
download and open the file most malware
email attachments include code our
exploits to cause your computer to
download more malware from the Internet
these email attachments are often small
customized and not widely spread making
them hard to detect by antivirus
software in recent years email malware
is often used to drop a ransomware which
can delete or encrypt your files and
backups even if they are stored in the
cloud or on a server malware or
malicious code is any element of
software that performs an unwanted
function from the perspective of the
legitimate user or owner of a computer
system malware is big business
not only are there hundreds of millions
of malware families and variants in the
world and an unknown number of
programmers developing the malware there
are also at least dozens of companies
developing anti-malware solutions the
developers who are working on writing
malware are getting paid to write the
software and disappearing selling of
this malware or expect to make money
from the malware operations going
through the different types of malware
you will start to understand the
complexity of the landscape today this
includes the functions of malware as
well as the users marah's have been
known to evolve em system resources a
good example is that of a warm which is
a self-contained application that
typically are focused on replication and
distribution rather than on direct
damage and disruption it
functions as a standalone piece of
software in that it can spread without
intervention by another program and it
focuses on spreading from an infective
system to as many on affected systems as
possible
a warm infection may display symptoms
that include a slow to response system
applications that no longer will execute
a lack of free space on storage devices
CPU and memory utilization maxed out at
hundred-percent system crashes and
abnormal Network activity this results
in a denial of service attack some
malware can create backdoors
compromising the system's security a
backdoor is a malware which allows a
hacker to remotely access your system
these small maliciously purpose tools
can easily be deposited on a computer
through a Trojan horse a virus of warm
or website mobile code download or even
as part of an intrusion activity once
active on a system the tool opens access
ports and waits for an inbound
connection
thus a backdoor serves as an access
portal for hackers so that they can
bypass any security restrictions and
gain access to a system for example
Microsoft has a backdoor which is used
to update the patches periodically it is
possible for an attacker to use this
backdoor to attack the system remotely
some malware such as retrovirus is known
to disable security functions
retroviruses are specifically targeted
at antivirus systems to render them
useless you can consider a retrovirus
to be an anti anti virus retroviruses
can directly attack your antivirus
software and potentially destroy your
virus definition database file
destroying this information without your
knowledge would leave you with a false
sense of security the virus may also
directly attack an anti-virus program to
create bypass for itself as discussed
earlier mal res can be used to create
botnets for a DDoS attack botnets are
either directly or indirectly controlled
by a hacker
a botnet can be used to perform any type
of malicious activity although they're
most often used to perform denial of
service flooding attacks botnets can
send hundred
and millions of requests to a website
causing a website to crash and not
available for legitimate users the best
defense against a botnet is to keep your
systems patched and hardened and not to
become the hosts of a botnet agent
malware's are often copied from one
location to another
using various methods removable media
such as USB pen drives are a major
source of malware it is generally a good
practice to disable the use of such
removable media to not only protect
against malware but also against theft
of confidential data documents and
executable files can be used to spread
malware across systems generally is a
good practice to not allow normal users
the ability to install executable files
in their system Internet is the source
for millions of malicious files that can
be easily downloaded and can infect the
systems a firewall rule should be
configured to prevent the download of
such malicious files several malware
such as warm can easily spread across
network connection a system infected
with warm must immediately be
disconnected from the network to prevent
it from infecting other systems in the
network as discussed earlier email
attachments could contain malicious
links or files always be cautious of
any attachments and scan them before
downloading if the primary purpose of
the malware application is to deliver
ads then it is classified as adware the
primary purpose of adware is to display
malicious ads and generate revenue for
the creator so Malory's are designed to
display pop up over legitimate content
these pop-ups could contain malicious
links and some of them could contain
phishing content which are difficult to
detect as these new threats have
developed so to have some excellent
programs for countering them keep your
updates current because this is where
most of the corrections for security
problems are implemented in this demo
you will learn how to create and deploy
a virus using the Metasploit framework
we will use the MSF venom command
available in Kali Linux to create a
standalone binary that will create a
reverse
pretty she'll back to us the - P option
specifies the payload to use which in
this demo is the windows Mira Peter Mira
Prater allows an attacker to control a
victim's computer by running an
invisible shell and establishing a
communication channel back to the
attacking machine el host option should
be used to specify your IP address which
in this case is one ninety two dot one
sixty eight dot 41.1 twenty nine L put
option should be the port you wish to be
connected back on which in this case is
double for double for - F specifies the
output format which in this case is exe
- a specifies the architecture to use
save the file as setup.exe press Enter
give it a moment to generate the payload
wonderful the exe file with the payload
is now generated now let's run the MSF
console command this will start the
Metasploit framework console use exploit
multi handler to handle exploit set
pollute Windows Media Player reverse TCP
reverse TCP to get the signal from host
said l host IP address here you set your
own IP address said l port as double for
double for set any port that you want
now the standard port like HTTP uses
port 80 exploit and wait for the victim
to click on this setup file after this
copy the virus folder into the pendrive
and paste it into the windows then run
the file on Windows system and then you
will see that the reverse TCP will get
the details of the computer where the
file was executed here are the commands
LS lists the files on victim system PWD
displays the current directory sis info
gets the system information help gets
all the commands related to the present
directory
times
the man's password database command hash
dump privilege elaborate command gate
system here the webcam commands control
your webcam these are the various
options available
back in the window system open up some
files
this is Bank credentials and you're very
sensitive passwords file the back in
your Kali Linux type the screenshot
command and this will save the
screenshot on your system let's open the
file and now you can see that the very
sensitive file is now being displayed
here in the screenshot I hope you
enjoyed the demo this demo will show you
to create unlimited new folder virus
type this code on notepad
this creates a infinite loop to create
random folders and save it as dot bat
file dot bat fine means that it will
execute in command prompt create a
folder called documents and place the
file dot bat inside this folder now run
the file where you want and it will
start creating unlimited folders you can
press shift-z to terminate this command
type why to terminate this batch job you
can see that there are thousands of
folders that have been created click on
this folder and you can see that these
folders are all empty hope you liked the
demo
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simple learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here